a short time ago we learned the nominees
for the 90th Academy Awards coming up on
March 4th the shape of water leads the
pack with 13 nominations anything up to
be the one to beat this year's Best
Actress nominees are Sally Hawkins
Frances McDorman Margot Robbie schwarzy
Ronan and Meryl Streep the nominees for
Best Actor are Timothy sha'lame Daniel
day-lewis Daniel kahlúa from get out
Gary Oldman and Denzel Washington and
the best director nods they go to
Christopher Nolan for Dunkirk Jordan
Peele for get out breaded Greta Gerwig
for Lady Bird I know that's good - Paul
Thomas Anderson for Phantom threat and
Guillermo del Toro for the shape of
water and the nine Best Picture nominees
this year are call me by your name
darkest hour Dunkirk get out Lady Bird
phantom thread the post the shape of
water and three billboards outside a
being Missouri the Motion Picture
Academy and its accounting firm
PricewaterhouseCoopers pronouncing new
rules because of last year's envelope
blunder when lala land was announced as
the Best Picture winner instead of
moonlight and then I heard Norah that
they have like six different fail-safes
to make sure